So personal motivation for
an app has really kind of
guided my learning,
as far as iOS development goes.
One of the first apps that I really
wanted to build was an app for
reading comics.
When I started reading
comics on my iPad,
there weren't a ton of apps
that were really good.
So, I started looking into
what the problem entailed and
it included things like opening up
zip files and reading byte data.
And without that motivation for
developing this tool for
myself, even though it may not
be useful for anybody else.
I never would have gathered that
knowledge and learned all the different
things about the lower level development
that I otherwise wouldn't have